[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis quoi hier
nous ne sommes pas venus vous voir vous
savez pourquoi
mais j'espère qu'aujourd'hui petit louis
et mirabel ont été gentils ça et vous
avez vous été sage répondre aux aurès
wire allons allons
alors allo allo allo allo kg est à
l'appareil
bonjour ou bien rappelle bonjour t-il
oui ce sont nos deux petits coquins à
noël au hall alors qu est ce qu on
entend balle allô allô retour aux
sources
tu sais maintenant on est très sage
on t'attend de l'auteur soit dit tu
viens de dire bonsoir je te plonge
jusqu'à minutes dans les rangs de dos il
craquait à venir
oui il a dit oui et dessins
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et coutumes nos chéris
on était méchant d'autres jours mais tu
sais c'est fini on ne sait pas plus
je compte en double moi aussi les
enfants
je vous aime vous en faites une petite
ronde et on va se coucher
d'accord d'accord d'accord
honda picotin oui moi là bas
[Musique]
picotte m'a mis un peu plus gros que je
peux courir ici
[Musique]
keyyo de wimax en vol ou au sol en se
tenant aucun d'eux n'est pas ma loi ne
nous donne pas elle non
oui oui votre wii patron c'est ulysse
des banques
si vous êtes sages ils sont déjà au lit
ils vous disent hors de lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
onu mirabel bonne nuit petit louis
bonne nuit tous les petits enfants aller
vite au dodo est faite de doux rêves
plat allons allons en bourse en route
allons vite nous coucher nous aussi à
demain à demain les enfants à demain
[Musique]